[Music]
so what's your name anyway
hey kid it's a big shot gangster he's
putting together crew you think
everything sounds like a bad idea if you
come with me you're in this life for
good I waited a long time for a shot
like this I got a really good feeling
about this
[Applause]
[Music]
you're after something is it revenge
[Music]
money
what is it something else good little
rough around the edges good heard about
a job big shot gangster putting together
crew I'm a driver and I'm a flier
the waited a long time for a shot like
this
what do you think well what do you know
you got a line on a ship yeah no guy
he's the best mug you around I heard a
story about you I was wondering if it's
true everything you said about me it's
true l-3 let's go with a mean man's face
these guys
if you come with us you're in this life
for good
might wanna buckle up baby
[Music]
let me give you some advice assume
everyone will betray you
and you'll never be disappointed I got a
really good feeling about this
since when do you know how to fly a
hundred and ninety years old look great
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]